للمزيد حول حاله الوضع الانسانيه
والصعوبات التي يجدها العاملون في قطاع
الصحي
لتعامل مع الحالات الطارئه ومع هذه
ظروف التي يمر منها السودان ينضم الى
اسامه ابو بكر عثمان مدير اداره التواصل
في الهلال الاحمر السوداني مرحبا بك هذه
الاسامه ابو بكر عثمان ما الذي يتركز او
يصبوا عليه اهتمامكم الان في ظل هذه
التحديات الامنيه
اهتمامنا في ضروره اخلاء المصابين والجرحى
من المناطق اخلاء وتقديم الاسعافات
الاوليه ونقلهم الى اقرب مستشفيات الهلال
احمد السوداني يعمل لرفع
القدره بتاعه المستشفيات التي في ظروف
صعبه جدا نحن شغالين في سبعه محافظات داخل
ولايه الخرطوم الكبرى سبع محافظات عندنا
اطقم
245 متطوع مدرب تدريب عالي في الاخلاق هو
في الاسعافات الاوليه وتقديم الرعايه
الصحيه الاوليه
ومن قلوبهم لاقرب المستشفيات
الصحيه في المستشفيات لانه في لخص عالي
جدا في الكوادر الصحيه اضافه لانه معظم
الكوادر الصحيه ما بيقدروا يوصلوا
المستشفيات لاسباب النزاع المسلح بالشوارع
في بعض المستشفيات بتعاني
من داخل هذه المستشفيات
وبناشدوا انه
يتم اخلاقه من المستشفيات بعض
وفي كوارث الطبيه المستشفيات ايضا عشان
كده الهلال الاحمر السوداني احمد الناشده
لاطراف النزاع المسلح في السودان
هو بيان فاضل اليوم
23 السماح لفرقه الاسعاف الميدانيه لاخلاء
المصابين تناسب جمعيه الهلال الاحمر
السوداني النزاع من القوات المسلحه وقوات
الدعم السريع لسماح للفرقه الميدانيه
التابعه لها بمزاوله اعمالها الانسانيه
المتمثله في اخلاء المصابين والجرحى
والجراء الاسعافات الاوليه الضروريه
تمهيدا لنفسه من المستشفيات والمراكز
الصحيه القديمه وتقديم المساعده اللازمه
لتسهيل عمل الفرق الميدانيه في كل شانه
حمايه الضحايا من المدنيين جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر السوداني تؤكد التزامها لاثق
بمباديها المتفق عليها في الحركه الدوليه
للضريبه لحمه والهلال الاحمر وتنفيذ مبدا
وعدم التحيز في اداء عملها الانسان
في احترام احترام النزاع
المنصوص عليها في اتفاقيه جنيفر لعام 1949
والقوانين الدوليه الخاصه لحمايه اسامه
تحدثت عن ضروره اجلاء المصابين والجرحى
الى المستشفيات هؤلاء المصابون هل لديكم
اي تقديرات او الجرحى هل لديكم اي تقديرات
او معلومات عن اعدادهم
وكيفيه الوصول اليهم
يلا نحن عندنا عندنا الاحصائيات بنعتدل
على هي الاحصائيات اللي بيعملوها متطوعين
لنا في الميدان
اديك احصائيات لو بتحب عندنا سبعه محليات
طبعا دي الاحصائيات بتاعه امبارح والامس
لسه يوم اليوم
يوم امس عندنا في السبعه محليات المحليه
في اكثر من 35 حاله
في
لمستشفيات
عن التفاصيل تعطي المستشفيات مستشفى ام
بدو مستشفى الراجحي في منطقه كالوري في
برضه في منطقه ام درمان في عملنا اكثر من
31 حاله لمستشفى
الثورات
النوم
في عندنا اكثر
[موسيقى]
مقسمه الى مستشفيين برضو مستشفى الكباس
ومستشفى بحري عند المسجد الاولياء اكثر من
80 حاله في مستشفى الجبل ومستشفى
التركي وفي المستشفى
النيل
والخرطوم 35 حاله الجمله 3 حاله
التي تم التعامل معها في الهلال الاحمر
ووصلناها لحد المستشفيات وتم التعاون معها
داخل المستشفيات 1555 حاله من الاصابات
المتوسطه
و191 حاله من الاصابات
هذه هذه الحالات السيد اسامه هذه الحالات
هل كلها عسكريه ام بينهم مدنيون
يلا عندنا احنا معظم المدنيين وفي بعض
الحالات العسكريه نحن بالنسبه لينا ما
بنسوي اي شخص مصاب محتاجه مساعده بغض
النظر عن انتمائه لكن هي حالات من
المدنيين